This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你们是在和一位深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少人背负着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你需要这样做，去听学。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
通过iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，以艰难的方式收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方搜索数字TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们开始自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
On The Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回顾过去》播客节目中。1979年，那对我是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. It is so great to have you here back for us. another episode. Before we get into it, though, I firstly just want to say thank you, a huge thank you for all of the support in 2022. We are coming into 2023, into the new year, strong,
84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“回顾过去”。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众。很高兴你们能回来收听我们。又一集节目。不过，在开始之前，我首先只想表达感谢，非常感谢大家在2022年给予的所有支持。我们将迈入2023年，迈入新的一年，充满力量，
happy and ready for so many more interesting topics and episodes. And there is so much to look forward to so much. But today we're going to begin our new year by tackling, I think, one of the biggest and most underrated concepts that many of us will come across in our 20s. If you've ever struggled with feeling like you don't know yourself anymore, you've become separated from who you truly are, you change yourself, depending on the people you're around, depending on your friends or your family, or you might just be feeling a little bit lost. This episode is for you, because today we are talking about how to, to embrace our authentic selves.
快乐并且准备好迎接更多有趣的话题和剧集。有那么多值得期待的事情，真的非常多。但今天我们要通过探讨我认为我们在20多岁时会遇到的最大且最被低估的概念之一，来开启我们新的一年。如果你曾挣扎于觉得自己不再了解自己，你已经与真正的自己疏远了，你根据身边的人、根据你的朋友或家人而改变自己，或者你可能只是觉得有点迷失。这一集就是为你准备的，因为今天我们要讨论的是如何拥抱我们真实的自我。
This is one of the most crucial things that we do need to accomplish in our 20s. And although it's not easy, although it's misunderstood, the outcomes, the benefits, they're not only lifelong, but they're pretty endless. When we're able to really connect and be our true selves, be true to our values, be honest about who we are and vulnerable, so much research, so many studies, show that we are happier, we're more fulfilled, our relationships are better, and we are just, you know, overall, better versions of ourselves. So today we are going to break down some of the essential psychology behind embodying authenticity. We're going to discuss the true meaning of
这是我们在20多岁时需要完成的最关键的事情之一。尽管这并不容易，尽管它被误解，但其结果和好处不仅是终身的，而且是相当无止境的。当我们能够真正建立联系并成为真实的自己，忠于我们的价值观，诚实地面对我们是谁并展露脆弱时，大量研究和许多研究表明，我们会更快乐，更有成就感，我们的关系会更好，而且我们只是，你知道，总体上成为更好的自己。所以今天我们要剖析体现真实性背后的核心心理学。我们将讨论真实的真正含义
authenticity and the reasons why it is so crucial. We're going to explore what happens when we become disconnected or separated from our authentic selves and why this is happening more and more in modern day society. And finally, of course, how do we find our way back? How do we fully embrace who we are and live through our authentic selves through things like honesty, boundaries, generosity and of course self-exploration. There is so much to cover. And the research, oh my gosh, the studies are fascinating. I have been having such a crisis of authenticity recently
以及为什么它如此至关重要的原因。我们将探讨当我们与真实的自我失去联系或疏离时会发生什么，以及为什么这种现象在现代社会中越来越普遍。最后，当然，我们如何找到回家的路？我们如何通过诚实、界限、慷慨以及当然还有自我探索等方式，完全拥抱我们是谁并活出真实的自我。有太多内容需要涵盖了。而且研究，天哪，这些研究太迷人了。我最近一直在经历这样一场真实性危机
and it can be so incredibly painful, I think, to feel like the version of yourself that you are presenting to others is not who you actually are. There have been so many times I have changed myself for the people I'm around, for the people I'm dating, with the people I'm friends with. And something I've realized is that, honestly,
而且我认为，觉得自己向别人呈现的那个版本的自己并不是真正的自己，这种感觉会非常非常痛苦。有太多次，为了我身边的人，为了我约会的人，为了我的朋友，我改变了自己。我意识到的一件事是，老实说，
life is too short. Life is too short to not be exactly who you are. So let us learn and grow together and explore how it is that we can embody and embrace our authentic selves. As we always do, let's begin with the basics. Let's begin with the foundations. So what actually is the authentic self? The authentic self, it's sometimes known as the true self as well.
生命太短暂了。生命太短暂了，绝不能不做真正的自己。所以让我们一起学习和成长，探索我们如何能够体现和拥抱真实的自我。一如既往，让我们从基础开始。让我们从地基开始。那么，真实的自我究竟是什么？真实的自我，有时也被称为真正的自我。
And it is a concept that's been around for a while. And it's discussed back in history by people like Socrates and Freud. Although it has a long history, I would say, it definitely hasn't lost its relevance in the modern day. And it remains just as important to understand, especially in our 20s, when the pursuit of the authentic self, I think, is one of the most crucial journeys that we all have to embark on as individuals. Discovering our authentic self is also really, really crucial for our well-being and our
这个概念已经存在一段时间了。苏格拉底和弗洛伊德等历史人物都曾对其进行过讨论。尽管它有着悠久的历史，但我可以说，它在现代绝对没有失去其相关性，而且理解它依然至关重要，尤其是在我们的20多岁时，我认为对真实自我的追求是我们每个人作为个体必须踏上的最关键的旅程之一。发现真实的自我对于我们的幸福和
relationships, not just with others, but with ourselves as well. If we don't have that keen awareness or that understanding of who we are or what we stand for, I think it's one of those things where we can never actually truly be seen or understood. So the depth of our relationships, the depth of our knowing of ourselves, the depth of our self-awareness is never going to be at the place that it truly needs to be. So essentially, our authentic self is who we are at our very core when all of the distractions and the facades are gone. and when we are truly stripped back and vulnerable, that's what remains. That's our authentic selves. And it's the part of you that would exist regardless of others' expectations,
人际关系也真的非常关键，不仅是与他人的关系，也是与我们自己的关系。如果我们没有对我们是谁或我们代表什么的敏锐意识或理解，我认为这就属于那种我们永远无法真正被看到或理解的情况。因此，我们人际关系的深度，我们对自己了解的深度，我们的自我觉察的深度，将永远无法达到它真正需要的高度。所以本质上，真实的自我就是当我们剥去所有的干扰和伪装时，我们在最核心处的那个自己。当我们真正卸下防备并展现脆弱时，留下的就是那个。那就是我们真实的自我。它是那样一部分的你：无论他人的期望如何，它都将存在，
regardless of where you are in the world or who you are with. It's this essence, this deep essence of who you are as an individual. In psychology, authenticity, it's more than merely trying to be ourselves. It requires a lot more than that. It requires action and truth and honesty and at the end of the day owning what you believe, what you desire and your strengths and weaknesses, along with what you choose to do with all of those things. It's also not just something that we happen across.
无论你在世界的哪个角落，无论你和谁在一起。它是这种本质，作为个体的你的内心深处的本质。在心理学中，真实性不仅仅是试图做我们自己。它需要更多的东西。它需要行动、真理和诚实，归根结底，是要对你的信仰、你的欲望以及你的长处和短处负责，并承担你对所有这些事情的选择。这也不是我们偶然遇到就能得到的东西。
It can take us years, years, sometimes even decades for some people to fully embrace and discover who we are. But once we do it, I think it is one of those things. that never goes out of style. It never loses its merit. It's such a valuable thing to do. So our authentic selves, it's made up of a few components. And there is a bit of a debate about this within the discipline of psychology, about the contents of the authentic self. But the main elements that tend to come up include things like our values, our beliefs, judgments, our desires, our temperament, which is a really important one.
对某些人来说，这可能需要数年、数年，甚至几十年的时间才能完全拥抱并发现我们是谁。但一旦我们做到了，我认为这是那种永远不会过时的东西。它永远不会失去其价值。这是一件非常有价值的事情。所以我们真实的自我，它由几个部分组成。在心理学学科内部，对于真实自我的内容，其实也存在一些争论。但往往会出现的主要元素包括我们的价值观、我们的信仰、判断、我们的欲望、我们的气质（这是一个非常重要的要素）。
And then things like our mission, our creativity, our free will. And finally, that recognition, that feeling, that acknowledgement of being alive, of being our own person and of being in control of who we are and the actions that we take. These are, I guess, what make up the authentic self. But it isn't just a list of how we would describe ourselves. isn't just a box of different things. It's also a verb, and our authentic self requires action to realize.
然后是我们的使命、我们的创造力、我们的自由意志。最后，那种认知、那种感觉、那种对活着的承认、对成为我们自己的承认，以及对控制我们自己是谁和我们采取的行动的承认。这些，我想，构成了真实的自我。但这不仅仅是一份关于我们如何描述自己的清单。它不仅仅是一个装着不同事物的盒子。它也是一个动词，我们真实的自我需要通过行动来实现。
Individuals who we would consider to live in alignment with their true self or their authentic selves, they are these people who are able to recognize and accept themselves for who they truly are. That's not just the good stuff, right? I think often we have a tendency to characterize ourselves by the things that we're good at,
那些被我们认为生活在与其真实的自我或真实自我相一致之中的人，他们是能够认识并接纳真正的自己的人。这不仅仅指好的一面，对吧？我认为通常我们有一种倾向，即通过我们擅长的事情来给自己贴标签，
by our jobs or by the things that we see merit in. But in order to understand our authentic selves, we also have to be able to recognize the ugly things about ourselves, the bad things, our weaknesses. People who are in alignment with their authentic selves, they also strive to align their actions, what they choose to do with their core values and their beliefs in that hope of sinking everything they do,
通过我们的工作或者我们认为有价值的事情。但为了理解我们真实的自我，我们还必须能够认识到我们身上丑陋的一面、不好的一面、我们的弱点。那些与真实的自我保持一致的人，也努力使他们的行动、他们的选择与他们的核心价值观和信仰保持一致，怀着将他们所做的一切融为一体的希望，
and discovering who they are in kind of tandem with everything else in their lives. So acting in one way at all times and in alignment with their true selves. And these are the people who we see, I'm sure some of us know them, who express themselves really freely, who act with consistency. They are the people we see and who we meet, who seem almost free from others' expectations, societal norms, but mostly they don't deny who they are. and they don't deny who they believe they are and what they want to do with their lives
并在生活的方方面面中发现自己是谁。从而在任何时候都以某种方式行事，并与他们真正的自我保持一致。这些人就是我们所看到的、我相信我们中的一些人也认识的人，他们非常自由地表达自己，行事具有一致性。他们是我们看到并遇到的人，似乎几乎摆脱了他人的期望、社会规范，但最重要的是，他们不否定自己。他们不否定他们认为自己是谁，以及他们想用自己的生活做什么
and what their impact on the world will be. This is because authenticity as an idea, but also as something that we embody, it almost illuminates that path forward to live the life that you want. When you are clear with yourself about what matters, you begin to understand how to make decisions that are going to align with your goals and with your identity and your core values. And you begin to build a life for yourself that does have meaning and does have joy. And I know if this sounds a bit like, you know, New Age Enlightenment, I don't blame you from
以及他们对世界的影响会是什么。这是因为真实性作为一个概念，同时也作为我们体现的一种事物，它几乎照亮了前方的道路，指引你过上自己想要的生活。当你对什么对你重要有清晰的认识时，你便开始明白如何做出与你的目标、你的身份和你的核心价值观相一致的决策。你开始为自己建立一个有意义且充满快乐的生活。我知道如果这听起来有点像，你知道的新时代启蒙，我不怪你
thinking this. I can understand how a lot of the words we're using sound pretty wishy-washy. But psychology as a discipline, as a scientific discipline, has shown us time and time again, that this version of us does exist. The authentic self does exist. And the people who are able to access it are by far some of the happiest people in the world. And in contrast to all of this and the authentic self,
这样想。我能理解我们使用的许多词汇听起来有多么空洞。但心理学作为一门学科，一门科学学科，一次又一次地向我们展示，这个版本的我们确实存在。真实的自我确实存在。那些能够接触到它的人绝对是世界上最快乐的人。与这一切和真实的自我形成鲜明对比的是，
there is also this false self, right? This inauthentic self. And that refers to almost a defensive facade or disguise that we tend to create to protect us from judgment or to conform and to be who others want us to be. This inauthentic self, it's viewed as doing our duty, rather than acting out of desire and from a place of honesty and vulnerability. And when people act in ways that go against or violate their true self,
还有一个虚假的自我，对吧？这个不真实的自我。这指的是我们为了保护自己免受评判，或者为了顺从并成为别人希望我们成为的人，而倾向于创造的一种防御性外观或伪装。这个不真实的自我，被视为是在尽职责，而不是出于欲望、出于诚实和脆弱的地方来行事。当人们的行为违背或侵犯了他们真实的自我时，
often there are emotional consequences that come along with that. You might experience negative feelings ranging from, you know, feeling a bit uncomfortable in a situation to feeling really guilty all the time or really shameful. Think about a time in your life when you did, when you did act in a way that you knew contradicted who you truly were at your core. Maybe you were working a job that didn't align with your values. You were distracting yourself with social media or acting in a way and treating others that contradicted your beliefs. In that moment, I think we all know this feeling, this tug in our chest, this panic, this distress, often some kind of mental reaction that
通常会伴随一些情绪后果。你可能会经历负面情绪，从（你知道的）在某种情况下感到有点不舒服，到一直感到非常内疚或非常羞耻。想想你生命中的某个时刻，你确实做了，确实以某种你知道与你核心真正的自我相矛盾的方式行事。也许你正在从事一份不符合你价值观的工作。你用社交媒体分散自己的注意力，或者以某种违背你信仰的方式行事并对待他人。那一刻，我想我们都知道这种感觉，胸口被猛地一拉，这种恐慌，这种痛苦，通常某种心理反应
indicates to us that something isn't quite right. That feeling is in itself pretty revealing, and it's something we have to learn to listen to, which is what we're going to discuss in a second. But I think it's also important to acknowledge that there is this kind of longstanding debate. right like we've talked a lot about the existence of the authentic self the fact that this thing is real what some of the consequences are but there is this kind of i would say yeah this discussion this debate within psychology about whether we do possess an innate authentic self that is permanent and long lasting or whether this version of ourselves changes over time but regardless of what you think one thing remains true
向我们表明有些事情不太对劲。这种感觉本身相当具有启示性，这是我们必须学会倾听的东西，这也是我们一会儿要讨论的内容。但我认为同样重要的是承认这里存在着某种长期存在的争论。对吧，就像我们已经讨论了很多关于真实自我的存在、这东西是真实的事实以及它的一些后果，但在心理学中确实存在这种讨论，这种辩论，即我们是否拥有一个永久且持久的内在真实自我，或者这个版本的我们是否会随着时间而改变，但无论你怎么想，有一件事仍然是真实的
when we are disconnected from our core values, our purpose and our characteristics and our desires, the result is not very pleasant and it's hard for us to be our best selves during these times. Not embodying our authentic self can actually be quite painful. You know, I've had a few times in my life where I've spent many hours crying in my car, feeling really terrible about myself because I didn't know who I was. When we're in our early 20s, we just feel so confused. And we're trying to figure out, is this really who I am? Is this what I want in my life?
当我们与核心价值观、目标、特性以及内心的渴望脱节时，结果往往并不美好，在这个时期我们也很难展现出最好的自己。不活出真实的自我实际上会非常痛苦。你知道，我的人生中曾有过几次，在车里哭了几个小时，对自己感到非常失望，因为我不知道我是谁。在我们二十岁出头的时候，我们总是感到无比迷茫。我们在努力弄清楚，这真的是我吗？这就是我想要的生活吗？
Does this align with my values? And I didn't know if anything I was doing actually did align with that version of me. And although I wasn't able to identify what exactly was going wrong, why exactly I was feeling that way, those moments were really scary and really painful to experience because who really are we if we are not connected to our true self, the things that we want, the qualities we embody, the person we are at our core. If you're going through this right now, you deserve a lot of credit because it is so difficult and there's a reason behind this. most psychologists which suggest that it's because we are ignoring and suppressing our authentic
这符合我的价值观吗？我不知道我所做的任何事情是否真的与那个版本的我相符。虽然我无法确切指出哪里出了问题，也说不清为什么会有这种感觉，但那些时刻经历起来真的让人感到恐惧和痛苦，因为如果我们与真实的自我、我们想要的东西、我们体现的品质以及我们内心的本质失去联系，我们究竟是谁呢？如果你现在正经历这一切，你应该为自己感到自豪，因为这太艰难了，而且这一切背后都是有原因的。大多数心理学家会认为，这是因为我们在那些时刻忽视和压抑了真实的
selves in those moments and what we're actually doing is pretending and finding a way to mask who we truly are this takes a lot of mental energy to pretend to be someone you're not and that exhaustion has some pretty real mental consequences you know imagine if every single moment of your life you were acting out some characters, someone else who you didn't really understand, who you didn't really believe in. It's exhausting. It's like having a full-time job that the clock never stops on. And additionally, we can feel a lot of guilt and shame if we're acting in a way that doesn't align with our core values and beliefs. Because what it really does is go against this core belief system. It's confusing and there's a sense of us that knows either through societal teaching
自我，而我们实际在做的是伪装，并寻找方法来掩饰真正的自己。伪装成一个不是自己的人需要消耗大量的心理能量，而这种疲惫会带来非常现实的心理后果。你知道，想象一下，如果你生活中的每一个时刻都在扮演某种角色，扮演一个你并不真正了解、也不真正相信的其他人。这太累了。这就好比做一份永远不会下班的全职工作。此外，如果我们行事的风格与我们的核心价值观和信念不符，我们就会感到内疚和羞愧。因为这实际上违背了核心信念系统。这让人感到困惑，并且我们在某种程度上通过社会教育
and societal learning that when we act out against who we actually are, the consequences are sometimes severe and it can just be really painful. There was a recent study published in psychological science and it found that hiding your authentic self, it produces feelings of immorality and impurity. So throughout the course of these five experiments, these scientists, these researchers, got these participants to act out in these certain different conditions. And participants reported that when they were made to be inauthentic, when they were asked to act in a way that didn't align with how they believed, it made them feel really immoral. And it increased this desire to do something, to almost redeem themselves. And on the other hand, when participants were able to act in a way that did align with their authentic selves or when they were asked to recall a time when they had behaved with authenticity, it actually made them feel really positive about themselves. There are some other studies that really back this up.
和社会学习了解到，当我们违背真实的自我行事时，后果有时会很严重，而且这确实非常痛苦。《心理科学》杂志最近发表的一项研究发现，隐藏真实的自我会产生不道德和不纯洁的感觉。因此，在整个五项实验过程中，这些科学家和研究人员让这些参与者在某些不同的条件下行事。参与者报告说，当他们被迫表现得不真实，被要求以一种不符合他们信念的方式行事时，这让他们觉得自己非常不道德。并且，这增强了他们去做某事以几乎自我救赎的欲望。另一方面，当参与者能够以符合真实自我的方式行事，或者当他们被要求回忆一段自己表现得真实的经历时，这实际上让他们对自己的感觉非常好。还有其他一些研究也强有力地支持了这一点。
One was in 2008. It found that people who are more authentic, they feel happier, they have self-esteem. They were even doing research on this back in the 90s. And they discovered that when you show up authentically as yourself, this actually brings greater satisfaction and lower stress levels, particularly in the workplace or in certain social situations. Being authentic, it's also super important for our relationships. I'm going to give you guys some more research here just because I think it is so fascinating. In 2006, these researchers showed that authenticity increased satisfaction in romantic
其中一项是在2008年进行的。研究发现，更真实的人感觉更快乐，拥有自尊。早在90年代，人们就已经在对此进行研究了。他们发现，当你真实地展现自我时，这实际上会带来更高的满足感和更低的压力水平，特别是在职场或某些社交场合中。保持真实对于我们的关系也超级重要。我打算在这里给大家分享更多研究，纯粹是因为我觉得这太吸引人了。在2006年，这些研究人员表明，真实性将浪漫
relationships like threefold by a crazy amount. When we embrace our true selves, we are honest. We set boundaries and we don't need external validation to fulfill ourselves because we already know who we are. And all of this results in better relationships with others, whether it is family, friends, or a romantic partner. So there is someone who talks about this a lot who I absolutely love. Her name is Brne Brown. If you know who I'm talking about, oh my gosh, sending you big kisses and love.
关系的满意度提高了三倍，达到了惊人的程度。当我们拥抱真实的自我时，我们是诚实的。我们设定界限，并且不需要外部的认可来满足自己，因为我们已经知道自己是谁。所有这一切都能带来与他人更好的关系，无论是家人、朋友还是浪漫伴侣。所以有一个经常谈论这个话题的人，我非常喜欢她。她的名字叫布琳·布朗。如果你知道我在说谁，天哪，向你发送大大的亲吻和爱意。
I'm a big fan. I think she is incredible and she did this TED talk a little while ago. That was incredible. It was about embracing our authentic self. And she explains how authenticity is an essential part of developing meaningful relationships. I would really highly recommend listening to this TED talk, but what she essentially concludes is, that people show up with their vulnerabilities and living their truth. And when they do this, it allows them to truly connect and feel close to others. And in contrast, when we have that fear of rejection, when we are scared, when we haven't really done the work to figure out who we are, it often prevents us from expressing our authentic selves. They put up this mask and we
我是她的超级粉丝。我认为她不可思议，不久前她做过一次TED演讲。那真是太棒了。演讲内容是关于拥抱真实的自我。她解释了真实性如何成为建立有意义关系的重要组成部分。我真的强烈建议听一下这个TED演讲，但她本质上的结论是，人们带着脆弱感出现并活在真实中。当他们这样做时，它能让他们真正与他人连接并感到亲密。相比之下，当我们对被拒绝感到恐惧时，当我们害怕时，当我们没有真正花功夫去弄清楚自己是谁时，这往往会阻止我们表达真实的自我。他们竖起面具，我们
sometimes change our behavior in order to fit in and in order to have people think about us a certain way and we're not doing ourselves any favors by acting that way. There is no doubt that pursuing and embodying our authentic self can be really difficult, especially in your 20s when our brains aren't even fully developed. Our ideas about the world aren't even fully developed and therefore or embodying our authentic selves is going to be difficult. However, this decade is particularly pertinent because although our journey, I guess, towards authenticity is a lifelong process, there are certain times and certain periods of our lives that are more crucial and more important in which that exploration is more permissible.
有时会改变行为，以便融入集体，并让人们以某种方式看待我们，而以这种方式行事对我们自己没有任何好处。毫无疑问，追求和体现真实的自我可能会非常困难，尤其是在二十多岁的时候，我们的智力甚至还没有完全发育成熟。我们对世界的看法甚至都还没有完全成型，因此体现真实的自我将会是困难的。然而，这个十年特别相关，因为尽管我们走向真实自我的旅程是一个终生的过程，但我们生命中的某些时期更为关键和重要，在这些时期中这种探索更被允许。
In our 20s, we are given this crazy opportunity to experiment and to make mistakes. mistakes with our friends, with our partners, our hobbies, our jobs where we live, and we get to identify what feels right, what aligns with who we want to be. And we also have an opportunity, or I guess it also is the time in which most of us begin to question the beliefs that have been ingrained in us since childhood by, you know, our parents, by our community, by general society. And we get to decide whether these are what we actually believe or we're just kind of going along with the flow and conforming to what is expected of us. It goes without saying, I think, that our authentic selves are rather elusive beings. And I think in many ways, we are separated from
在我们二十多岁的时候，我们获得了这样一个疯狂的机会去尝试和犯错。与朋友、伴侣、爱好、工作、居住地一起犯错，我们得以辨别出什么感觉是对的，什么与我们想要成为的人相符。我们也有机会，或者说这也是我们大多数人开始质疑自童年起就被父母、社区、一般社会根深蒂固在我们心中的信念的时期。我们得以决定这些是否是我们真正的信仰，还是我们只是随波逐流并顺从于对我们的期望。不言而喻，我认为真实的自我往往是难以捉摸的存在。并且我认为在许多方面，我们与
this version of us by things like technology, by our relationships, by people pleasing, by just like the general busyness of everyday life, which keeps us disconnected from our core identity. So although we might be able to recognize that this decade is important for this journey and important for this discovery, there are so many things also occurring at the same time that are going to keep us preoccupied. Because we also have been very, you know, the world around us has changed. It's a lot more digital. There are a lot more distractions and drama. And during this decade, we often place a lot more, you know, a lot more importance in the significance of fleeting moments.
这个版本的自己被诸如科技、人际关系、取悦他人以及日常生活的一般忙碌等事物所隔绝，这使我们与核心身份保持着脱节状态。因此，尽管我们可能认识到这十年对于这段旅程和这种发现很重要，但同时也有太多的事情在发生，会让我们分心。因为我们也经历过，你知道，我们周围的世界已经发生了变化。它变得更加数字化了。有更多的干扰和戏剧性事件。在这个十年里，我们经常把更多的精力，你知道的，把更多的重要性放在稍纵即逝的时刻上。
and our daily tasks and our jobs and our relationships and our breakups and the drama in our friendship groups rather than the idea of who we actually are. And that keeps us separated. That keeps us disconnected. And even if we are in touch with the authentic version of who we are, the battle doesn't really stop there because there is such an intense pressure to conform to social norms and societal expectations for who we should be. And what that kind of means is that often we end up abandoning our wants, our desires, our individual differences to be perceived as quote unquote normal and conform. This kind of pressure to conform, it's often really subtle, so much so that it's not really noticed
以及我们的日常任务、工作、人际关系、分手和朋友圈里的戏剧性事件，而不是去思考我们究竟是谁这个概念。这让我们感到分离。这让我们感到脱节。而且，即使我们与真实的自我保持着联系，战斗也并不会就此停止，因为存在着如此巨大的压力去顺从社会规范和对于我们应该成为什么样的人的社会期望。这意味着，我们常常最终会放弃我们的需求、愿望和个人差异，以便被视为所谓的“正常”人并随大流。这种顺从的压力，通常非常微妙，以至于根本不会被注意到
until we get to the point of feeling immensely dissatisfied. When someone conforms, they put aside their personal preferences, they put aside their authentic selves, and they go along with the group. Because that's what conformity is all about. It's about aligning yourself with the majority.
直到我们感到极度不满为止。当一个人顺从时，他们会抛开个人的偏好，抛开真实的自我，随波逐流。因为这就是顺从的全部意义。它是关于让自己与大多数人保持一致。
And a willingness to conform, it stems from a deep desire to be accepted. and to have your membership to the groups that you belong to endorsed and you don't want to feel you know rejected this isn't necessarily an innately negative thing right like it's super normal to want to feel like you belong to want to be a member of your social groups and to have your membership endorsed to feel like you're connected and welcome but it is a bad thing when it disrupts your connection to your authentic self because that's the thing that's going to matter beyond
而顺从的意愿，源于被接纳的深切渴望，以及希望自己所属群体的成员身份得到认可，你不想感到被拒绝，你知道的。这并不一定是一件本质上消极的事情，对吧？就像想要感受到自己属于某个群体、想要成为社交圈的一员并让自己的成员身份得到认可、感到自己被连接和受欢迎，这超级正常；但当它破坏了你与真实的自我之间的联系时，它就是一件坏事，因为这才是超越
all of these things. Social groups come and go. Your membership to them will come and go, but your authentic self is something that is always going to be within you. So how do we push back against all of these factors, all of these kind of external pressures to pursue authenticity in the face of all of this? Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of immune system and my gut health. And with one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff. And it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro-habit that you can incorporate
所有这些事情中最重要的事情。社交圈来来去去。你对它们的成员身份会来来去去，但真实的自我却是永远存在于你之内的东西。那么，面对所有这些因素、所有这些外部压力，我们该如何进行反击，在这一切面前去追求真实呢？我们的下一个合作伙伴有一款我每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用AG1是因为我一直在进行健康之旅。我想要更好地照顾免疫系统和肠道健康。只需一平勺美味的AG1，你基本上就能吸收75种高质量的维生素、矿物质、益生菌以及所有这些好东西。它对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的非常棒。这只是一个你可以融入
into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly. And Athletic Greens is also a climate neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase.
日常生活中的简单微习惯，却能带来巨大的好处。它非常符合各种生活方式。而且Athletic Greens也是一家气候中立认证的公司，我们在节目中绝对喜欢这一点。现在，是时候重获健康，用便捷的日常营养武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在一杯水中加入一平勺。就是这样。无需为了照顾健康而吃成百上千种不同的药丸和补充剂。为了方便起见，Athletic Greens将在你首次购买时免费赠送你一年的支持免疫系统的维生素D以及五个免费旅行装。
All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash Gemma. Again, that's athletic greens. Gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. So there is this author. Their name is Kamau Ravi Kant. And they had this to say about discovering and I guess embracing our authentic selves. I thought it was so amazing. When I read this, I was like, this has to go on the episode. It's so incredible. This is what they had to say. We don't stumble accidentally into an amazing authentic. life. It takes a conscious commitment to figuring out what we stand for, finding our truth,
你所需要做的就是访问 athleticgreens.com/Gemma。再说一遍，那是 athleticgreens.com/Gemma，来掌控你的健康，并挑选终极的日常营养保障。所以有一位作家。他们的名字叫卡毛·拉维坎特（Kamau Ravi Kant）。他们对发现以及拥抱真实的自我发表了这样的看法。我觉得这太棒了。当我读到这段话时，我想，这必须放进这期节目里。它太不可思议了。这就是他们的看法。我们不会偶然跌入一个精彩且真实的生命中。
and it begins by looking inside ourselves, because when it rises from within, we have no choice but to express it and to live it. I love that. I think that's amazing. I think that sums up everything we're talking about, done and Dustin, we can move on, obviously joking. And, you know, I can't give you all the answers, but some of the research I looked into for this episode, completely aligned with what they had to say. And there are some amazing tips for getting us to our most true authentic self and embodying this version of us in everything that we do, every interaction we have, every relationship that we are in.
这需要我们做出清醒的承诺，去弄清楚我们代表什么，找到我们的真理，并且它始于审视我们的内心，因为当它从内部升起时，我们别无选择，只能表达它并活出它。我太喜欢了。我认为这太棒了。我认为这总结了我们正在谈论的一切，大功告成，我们可以继续前进了，当然是在开玩笑。而且，你知道，我无法给你所有的答案，但我为这期节目研究的一些资料，完全符合他们的说法。并且有一些很棒的建议，可以引导我们找到最真实的自我，并在我们所做的每一件事、每一次互动、以及我们身处の每一段关系中体现这个版本的自己。
So I'm going to talk through some of the things that we can tangibly do, some of the actions that can make our authentic selves a verb like we talked about. Firstly, I think I say this whenever we're talking about a process like this, but you actually need to be prepared to be super honest and vulnerable with yourself and to take a really hard look at yourself in the mirror. And one way of doing this is by putting aside 30 minutes and asking yourself the following questions. Firstly, what are the five biggest values that you want to embody? What are the five things about yourself, the five values and qualities that you love the most in which represent you? These values could be things like honesty, creativity, independence, strength, faith, love, courage, determination. There are so many.
因此，我将谈谈一些我们可以切实去做的事情，一些能够让我们的真实自我像我们谈到的那样成为一个动词的行动。首先，我想每当我们讨论这样一个过程时我都会说，你实际上需要做好准备，对自己超级诚实和脆弱，并且在镜子里面对自己进行非常严格的审视。做到这一点的方法之一是抽出30分钟，问自己以下问题。首先，你想体现的最大的五个价值观是什么？关于你自己，你最喜欢且最能代表你的五件事、五个价值观和品质是什么？这些价值观可以是诚实、创造力、独立、力量、信仰、爱、勇气、决心等等。有太多了。
But each of us will have at least five major ones that we believe define us. These are the values that we need to keep at the front of our minds. because they are core to who we are, and therefore they're core to our authentic selves. Secondly, I want you to reflect on what activities, what people, and what situations make you feel the most alive. And a way to identify this is to consider the times in your life in which you've entered a flow state. So our flow state, it's also colloquially known as like kind of being in the zone. And it refers to a time in which we are completely engrossed in an activity to the point where time and everything else in our lives kind of fades away. And this state of mind in which we are energized, in which we are focused and fully involved in what we're doing,
但我们每个人都会有至少五个定义我们的主要价值观。这些是我们必须时刻铭记在心的价值观，因为它们是我们是谁的核心，因此也是我们真实自我的核心。其次，我希望你反思一下，哪些活动、哪些人和哪些情况能让你感觉自己最有活力。识别这一点的方法是，思考你生命中进入心流状态的时刻。所以我们的心流状态，在口语中也被称为“进入状态”。它指的是我们全神贯注于某项活动，以至于时间和我们生活中的其他一切都逐渐褪去的时刻。这种充满活力、专注并全力投入我们正在做的事情的心态，
it's one of the highest states of consciousness that we can be in. and it indicates that we are doing something that aligns with our authentic self. Think about the friends with whom you can talk for hours, about everything and anything, without looking at your phone or worrying about the outside world. Those are the people to hold close because in their presence you can be authentic. Think about the hobbies that you can be consumed by and effortlessly find yourself wrapped up in, whether it's painting, running, I don't know, knitting, reading, listening to this podcast, I don't know, whatever it is, whatever it may be, these are the things that you should be doing more of. And find time to be doing these in your daily life, if not your weekly kind of plan.
是我们能够进入的最高意识状态之一，它表明我们正在做符合真实自我的事情。想想那些你可以和他们聊上几个小时的朋友，无话不谈，不用看手机，也不用担心外面的世界。那些是要紧紧抓住的人，因为在他们面前你可以做真实的自己。想想那些能让你全情投入、毫不费力地沉浸其中的爱好，无论是画画、跑步、我不知道，织毛衣、阅读、听这个播客，我不知道，无论它是什么，无论它可能是什么，这些都是你应该多做的事情。在你的日常生活中，如果不是在每周的计划中，也要腾出时间来做这些事情。
Set aside time to actively engage in the activities and the hobbies that make you feel alive. It does amazing things for your brain. It does amazing things for your well-being. it refreshes you and essentially it connects you with your authentic self and finally consider the issues the topics the ideas that really light your soul on fire which you could discuss for hours these are the ideas that fuel you and they represent the intricacies and the desires of your true self i think i've recommended these exercises in another episode but it's just as valuable here it's so important. I do this at least every three months. It's so, everyone has 30 minutes in their week,
留出时间积极参与那些让你感到生机勃勃的活动和爱好。它对你的大脑有神奇的作用。它对你的幸福感有神奇的作用。它能让你焕发活力，本质上它将你与真实的自我连接起来。最后，考虑那些真正点燃你的灵魂、你可以讨论几个小时的问题、话题和想法。这些是为你注入活力的想法，它们代表了你真实自我的复杂性和渴望。我想我在另一期节目中推荐过这些练习，但它在这里同样很有价值，非常重要。我至少每三个月做一次这个。每个人在一周内都有30分钟的时间，
30 minutes in their month, just to sit down and really do some thinking about it and it benefits you so much. It's like so, so powerful doing this. Take some time to really concentrate on it and journal your thoughts on it. I promise the results are so enlightening and it does bring you a step forward to your authentic self. Another tip and another, I think, crucial. thing you need to do is to speak your truth with unwavering certainty. I know I said speak your truth, but this also means representing yourself based on how you feel internally, whether that's what you wear, how you present yourself, the conversations you have, who you choose to be around. All of this is representative of your authentic self, and you do have to consciously and confidently
在一个月里有30分钟的时间，坐下来真正思考一下，这会对你大有裨益。这样做非常、非常有力量。花点时间真正集中精力，把你的想法写进日记里。我向你保证，结果会极具启发性，它确实能让你朝着真实的自我迈进了一步。另一个技巧，我认为你必须要做的至关重要的事，就是以坚定不移的确定性说出你的真理。我知道我说过说出你的真理，但这同时也意味着根据你的内在感受来代表你自己，无论是你穿的衣服、你展现自己的方式、你进行的对话，还是你选择与之相处的人。所有这一切都代表着真实的自我，你确实需要有意识且自信地
put this version forward without worrying about the judgment of others. A lot easier said than done. We've talked about a lot of the pressures that we find to lie, to create this facade to pretend. And it takes practice. But slowly integrating your deepest truths into who you choose to be. And also recognizing when you're trying to conceal this version of you or change who you are because you think others won't like this person, that's a really valuable thing we have to learn. And it involves taking daily actions towards authenticity. and also setting healthy boundaries with people who don't respect that version of you.
把这个版本展现出来，而不必担心别人的评判。说起来容易做起来难。我们已经讨论过很多为了说谎、为了制造虚伪假象而感受到的压力。这需要练习。但要慢慢地将你最深的真理融入到你选择成为的人之中。同时还要认识到，当你试图隐瞒这个版本的自己，或者因为你认为别人不会喜欢这个人而改变你是谁时，这是我们必须要学到的一件非常有价值的事情。这涉及到朝着真实性采取每日行动，并与那些不尊重那个版本的你的人设定健康的界限。
I think often our authentic selves can feel like a really big abstract concept. But when you really look at it, it really does just come down to daily actions. Because in those small moments, you build consistency, you build up that version of yourself every single day. And the things you say, your decisions, your actions, those add up to who you are. actualising an authentic life, it also starts with intentional planning and daily planning, like choosing who we surround ourselves with, how we go about our daily lives, the jobs we work, the places we live, and the small tasks and everyday behaviours that cumulatively build up into who we are.
我认为通常真实的自我感觉像是一个非常庞大的抽象概念。但当你真正审视它时，它确实归结为日常的行动。因为在那些微小的时刻里，你建立了一致性，你每天都在构建那个版本的自己。你所说的话、你的决定、你的行动，这些累加起来造就了你是谁。实现真实的生活，也始于刻意的规划和日常规划，比如选择我们与谁相处、我们如何过日常生活、我们从事的工作、我们居住的地方，以及那些累积成我们是谁的小任务和日常行为。
Make some small intentions with yourself or resolutions to do the things that make you, your authentic self happy, whether that is spending time in nature, nurturing others through acts of service, you know, cooking for them, or speaking passionately about what you believe. Even, you know, this is such a small one, but posting whatever the hell you want on social media. Social media is a huge way in which we can seal our authentic selves. I've had times where I'm like, oh, I really want to post this, but I'm not going to, because it's not how I want to represent myself. And it's like, no, just post it. If it's something you want to do, if it aligns with your desires, if it's your truth, you
对自己许下一些小小的愿望或决心，去做那些能让你、让真正的你感到快乐的事情，不管是亲近大自然、通过服务他人来关爱别人（比如为他们做饭），还是充满激情地谈论你的信仰。甚至，这只是件微不足道的小事，比如在社交媒体上发布任何你想发的内容。社交媒体是我们掩藏真实的自我的一种主要方式。我曾有过这样的时刻：哦，我真的很想发这个，但我不打算发，因为这不是我想展现自己的方式。这就好比，不对，发就对了。如果这是你想做的事，如果它符合你的欲望，如果是你的真心，你
should post it. Because our authentic self, it's built on each minute, each action, each decision, we deliberately decide to be who we truly are. Learn how to trust yourself and be independent. Often we become disconnected from our authentic selves because we're caught up in people pleasing or conforming with societal expectations. So take inventory of your life and decide what are the things that actually make you happy? What decisions are you in control of?
就应该发出来。因为真正的自我，是由我们刻意决定成为真实自己的每一分钟、每一个行动、每一个决定所构建的。学会相信自己并保持独立。通常，我们会与真实的自我失去联系，是因为我们陷入了讨好他人或迎合社会期望的泥潭。所以，盘点一下你的生活，决定一下究竟有哪些事情能真正让你快乐？你能够掌控哪些决定？
And take control of them. So often we do things we don't want to do. We are in jobs that we hate. We say yes to plans that we know are going to make us unhappy. And with every choice like that, we make ourselves separated further and further from all authenticity. So learn to trust yourself and say no to things that don't serve you and yes to things that do. When you are able to discover how to be your authentic self through some of those tips, through some of those ideas, through journaling, through daily practices, you live in the flow.
并且去掌控它们。我们经常做一些自己不想做的事。我们做着讨厌的工作。我们对那些明知会让自己不快乐的计划说“好”。而每一次这样的选择，都让我们与真正的自我渐行渐远。因此，学会相信自己，对那些无益于你的事情说“不”，对有益的事情说“当你通过其中一些技巧、一些想法、写日记、日常练习，能够探索出如何做真实的自己时，你就会活在心流之中。”
You're in a good state of mind and you trust your judgment. And what comes with that is this marvelous, consistent embodiment of your core values and beliefs. We feel more connected to ourselves. And as the studies have suggested, that means we have better relationships, greater connection with our environment and our internal world. We're happier. Isn't that something that everyone wants? Like it might be really difficult to do this, but there are so many people that never
你处于良好的精神状态，并且相信自己的判断。伴随而来的，是对你核心价值观和信念的一种精彩的、持续的践行。我们感到与自己的连接更加紧密。正如研究所表明的那样，这意味着我们拥有更好的关系，与环境和内心世界有更深厚的连接。我们更快乐。难道这不是每个人都想要的吗？虽然这可能很难做到，但有许多人从来不
make this decision, who spend their entire lives being a fake version of their cells, not being true to themselves. And most of them are deeply unhappy. And they get to a point in their life where they have this crisis. You know, they're 30, they're 40, they're 50, 60 years old. And they look around and they're like, I get one life. There is only a finite amount of time on this world. And I wasted that time being someone who I am not. And here's the thing, like, no one is looking at you as hard as you are looking at yourself. And the people who are their authentic selves, I'm sure we've all met them, they're amazing, they're bright, they're brilliant, and that could be you as well. Isn't that the most beautiful thing? Like, that could be you
做出这个决定，他们花了一生时间扮演虚假的自我，没有忠于自己。他们大部分人都深深感到不快乐。当他们到了人生的某个阶段，就会经历这种危机。你知道的，他们30岁、40岁、50岁、60岁了。环顾四周，他们会想：我只有一次生命。在这个世界上时间是有限的。而我却把时间浪费在成为一个连我自己都不是的人上面。问题是，没有人像你自己那样严厉地审视你。而那些做回真实自己的人，我相信大家都遇到过他们，他们是那么迷人、阳光、耀眼，而你也可以成为那样的人。这难道不是最美好的事情吗？那就是你
this year. What's not, like, you know, what is not to love about that? Nothing. So if this is something you're struggling with, I would highly recommend doing some of those mental exercises we discussed and being conscious of the person that you want to be. I know you can do it. And I think the other thing to remember is that although you're not going to stumble across your authentic self, it is going to take time. That version of you already exists. It's already within you and it can be discovered. I think it's so valuable to do in this decade. It's going to benefit your life exponentially, incredibly. You're going to attract better people, better romantic partners, better opportunities, and you're just going to be happier. So that was such a little bit of a
今年。有什么理由不爱呢？没有。所以，如果你正在为此苦恼，我强烈建议你做一些我们讨论过的心理练习，并对你想成为的那个人保持清醒的认识。我知道你能做到。我想另一件需要记住的事情是，尽管你不会偶然发现那个真实的自我，但这需要时间。那个版本的你已经存在了。它已经在你的内心深处，并且可以被发掘出来。我认为在这个十年里做这件事非常有价值。它将呈指数级、不可思议地让你的生活受益。你会吸引更好的人、更好的浪漫伴侣、更好的机会，而且你会更快乐。所以这只是一点点
speech there, a little bit of a indoctrinated speech, but I really do believe it. And it's something that I really want to focus on in this year in 2023. So if it's something that you want to focus on as well, well, you know, do a bit more research, but I feel like this is a good place to start. Thank you so much for listening to today's episode. That's all we have for this episode. I do feel like I could do a part two. Maybe not for a while. Maybe like a reflection on my own authentic self. I don't know. The idea has been swirling around in my head, but it's something I'm really into talking about at the moment. I'm talking about with so many of my friends. So I'm glad you could join in on the conversation. Thank you for listening. I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you did and if you do feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show to grow and to reach new people. And I know I said it at the start, but thank you for all of the love and support last year. This year is going to be amazing.
长篇大论，有点像说教式的演讲，但我确实深信不疑。这也是我在2023年非常想要专注于做的事情。所以，如果这也是你想专注的事情，好吧，你知道的，多做点研究，但我觉得这是一个很好的起点。非常感谢收听今天的节目。这就是本期节目的全部内容。我觉得我可以做第二期。也许不会等太久。也许是对我真实的自我的一种反思。我不知道。这个想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋，但这是我目前真的很热衷谈论的事情。我和我的很多朋友都在谈论它。所以我很高兴你能加入这个对话。谢谢收听。希望你喜欢这期节目。如果你喜欢，并且愿意这样做的话，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长和接触新听众非常有帮助。我知道我在开头说过，但谢谢大家去年所有的爱与支持。今年将会非常精彩。
There are so many plans. I'm so excited. So if you want to be the first. to know about those plans, please follow our Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. You also get to pick what episodes I publish. I do a poll every couple of weeks and let the listeners decide what they hear that week. So if you want to be involved in the community in that way, please feel free to do so. We would love to have you on board.
我们有很多计划。我太兴奋了。所以如果你想成为第一个了解这些计划的人，请关注我们的Instagram：That Psychology Podcast。你还可以选择我发布什么节目。我每隔几周就会做一次民意调查，让听众决定他们那周想听什么。所以如果你想以这种方式参与到社群中，请随时加入。我们非常欢迎你的加入。
And thank you again for listening. Happy 2023, here is to an amazing year of being and embracing our authentic selves. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
再次感谢收听。2023年快乐，让我们迎接充满拥抱真实自我的精彩一年。嘿，大家好，欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法进行的安全坦诚的对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
但你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养坚韧心智、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWO%，可在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手交往过时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想逃脱惩罚。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe》，可在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是Sam J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。